taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hi taste buddies it's the taste buds i'm
joe i'm sal
what's going on how are you today
everybody
on this lovely sunny afternoon yeah it
is kind of nice out
and it's not too cold out i mean it says
it's in the 30s but it's
it doesn't feel like it's in the 30s i
don't know the sun's out which is
means the guns are out and that's all i
need are you vibrant
vibrant i agree i like to rock out
with my son out that's not how it goes
flipped it no flipped it made it clean i
feel like we're both very uh
relaxed and engaged i'm relaxed finally
i had a hell of a morning you know it's
funny because you came in
unrelaxed and then you had a triple
espresso
yes and now you feel relaxed uh
it's what might be what is known as an
addict
oh so you didn't have your coffee yet i
had one cup
this morning you drink coffee every day
i drink it every day
several cups in the morning every day
several cups a day i had one cup this
morning but that was it and then i ran
around the bunch
and and i don't think it took and my
whole plan was that i was gonna on the
way on the drive from new york
city to staten island from manhattan to
staten island
i was gonna stop and get it nice
trying to get the right arm okay i was
gonna stop and get a nice big coffee
and i never for some reason never passed
a place you're in the camp of where you
gotta get up and have your car like
don't talk to me before i have my coffee
i am starting to become that person wow
and i haven't
i've i'm doing a little bit of a flush
out so i haven't drank in two weeks
mm-hmm i'll tell you not it's not pretty
what are you trying to flush out toxins
i'm just trying to kind of recalibrate
you know i mean during the pandemic
there was
there's been so much down time that
booze be
for at least for me became a little more
of a regular part of the the uh diet you
know
and i was like you know what i got to
kind of hit a reset here and just kind
of clear my brain and stuff
you like tea no you don't like tea at
all
i don't dislike it the ancient tea i
don't dislike it but i don't have time
for it
um you don't have time for it no no what
about when you have a cold or a
or like uh i don't drink it yeah yeah or
like so you don't you don't do a lot of
things when i'm sick
you don't go to tea for like to settle
you
at night or on a nice winter's day or
you know a nice glass of tea in the
morning with your breakfast or
a glass of tea after dinner your coffee
coffee coffee all the time yeah
in fact uh once in a while
some sleepy time tea before bed if i
feel like i really need to settle in man
i love tea
coffee i love it i've seen my whole life
i love iced tea
yeah yeah we did iced tea versus
lemonade is that out yet pimp
no it's not out yet okay that's coming
at you yeah and in fact i was lemonade
on that one
you were lemonade but i do like iced tea
but uh but yeah and not tea i mean look
that's
more importantly like whiskey yeah and
that's what's missing from my life
i understand yeah it stands yeah it's
not missing from mine
i know no i'm kidding i know i barely
what do i do
i don't drink i don't drink anymore
like i don't i couldn't tell you the
last time i was uh drunk or anything
like that okay
yeah well you're also a guy that
classically thinks he's never drunk
that's not true you i have that's not
true
i think there's a difference between
like like buzzed and shit-faced maybe
i'm making that maybe i'm making that
distinction
okay okay all right but yeah i feel nice
but no but honestly i don't really drink
a lot anymore at all
i don't even if i'm gonna drink i don't
drink a lot of drinks
if you're going back to the summer where
we were like masked up
bar hopping right just trying to have
some normal days when you would always
tell me you weren't drunk at all
several days one of them in which we
were pouring tequila out of a
bottle into each other's mouths on the
street that you were still claiming that
you weren't drunk that's
that's an exception that's an exception
i'm just saying that's
a total exception and you're making it
sound worse than it was the reason we
were doing that
is because okay let me let me let me
bring some clarity to that before we
even go on
uh bars were sparse and not always open
and closing early and we couldn't go
indoors and we
what we did was we were just walking so
we get some fresh air and talk and
socialize
that was all you could do back in the
heights of it yeah and that was when
they were allowing the walk tales they
called them sure
but then quickly they would close early
or bars would have very limited
resources
so we said instead of like not being
able to even find a bar and then paying
twenty dollars for some cheap liquor why
don't we just buy a bottle of alcohol
put in our backpack
and we can make our own drinks as we
walk around yeah and since it was
covered we weren't gonna
share bottles right so we had to lift
the bottle up and like
pour it in the air into our mouth what
you just described is exactly what i
said
it sounds no better that you're like
you're like the bars closed at 10. we
had
no choice but to buy a bottle and
drink it in the street it sounds worse
the way you said it
the way i said it sounded like kind of
like a cancun kind of like
like a lady walking by it yeah no i
thought you
just just sounded you made us sound like
hobos no
like we roamed the streets with bindles
like just pouring tequila into each
other's mouths pushing each other into
the bushes that far off
from that uh that was i could say that
night that specific night yes that was
um we drank a decent amount that night
but other than that i what i mean is
like
that was what six months ago there you
go i don't drink a lot
i don't i have a glass of wine with
dinner maybe two
maybe that's it though yeah yeah
all right
you gotta believe me
uh how many drinks a week is alcoholism
pimp is
excess is defined as 15 more drinks a
week i'm
way past that no way
not right now a week so i mean when we
used to go out and be young
wild and free like like like wild
stallions running the beaches i would
have are you telling drinks in the night
but are you telling me
on a normal week right 15 drinks in a
week yeah if you have two nights
okay of six seven drinks you're there
you did it okay but i'm not doing that i
suppose what i mean
right sure i'm saying i'm saying when
i'm having a drinking week
15 if you go out twice in a week if
you've got three nights in a week
that's five drinks each one of those
nights that's nothing yeah
i mean you know you know you know five
no i know but but when was the last time
i was trying to get a three night drinks
three night drinks i'm not saying you
were do you hear the defensiveness
i'm just pointing out how few drinks 15
years
that's what you're doing no i'm just
well you just told me before
you were on edge because you didn't have
your whiskey
i'm saying i flushed out the booze for a
couple weeks
right and yes you do notice that uh
at least for me you do notice that there
is none of that
by the way the guy's saying he's not he
doesn't drink he's got a whiskey
right there at 1 30 in the afternoon
and an entire bottle next to the couch
because he didn't want to have to go
back downstairs
all right wait a minute under the bus
already
first of all okay first of all you're
making it sound like i have a problem
i'm not i'm just saying i'm indulging
because you know what happens to me you
walk in and i go
oh i'm just craving whiskey when i see
you i'm so sure that's
the problem you have a problem you're a
trigger for me for whiskey dude
no there's no first of all there's no
need to talk about times
you don't have to let them let them know
it was 1 30. you didn't have to let them
know that it was a long one you said
it's a sunny day
you already said it was a sunny day yeah
but 1 30 i mean it could have been
4 30. you'd know that the earlier you go
the less it's acceptable
you really went in early afternoon on me
there you really identified it
because you're trying to create a
narrative i would disagree with you
about the earlier you go
i think you gotta either it's it's fine
first of all it's sunday okay so
if you want to even go by that people
drink on sunday the lord's day it's the
brunch
right it's the brunch crowd they're all
out there there's people all across the
land
out right now drinking alcohol today
yeah yeah no i know i know
people across land doing all kinds of
things okay i'll go back okay
we will get to this episode i will go
back i will go back i will tell you
besides okay this is gonna sound bad
again
besides the four bottles of wine i told
you i split for the yurana
season finale between
it was the most important i've ever
drank in my entire life in one sitting
ever
it's only because i just started
drinking red wine and it was and i
and and we hung out i hadn't seen my
friend a long time and and i did i did
drink two bottles of red wine
with each that was the i don't think
i've ever drank a bottle of wine before
in my life
and besides that i swear to god i can go
back six months of the summer before i
had more than two drinks in a sitting
okay
so today i was like i have that we know
that's not true because last time we
recorded we had a bunch of drinks
you did not have two tricks
though the last time we recorded we
recorded
up here on drake and you kept yelling at
me when my glass was empty
all right so you bought it one other
time the bottom line is i don't have any
problems okay
you came in here saying you were not on
edge because you didn't have your
80 proof i'm
i'm having this to sip okay it's nice
i understand i'm an adult i understand i
said i sip it all i'm saying it's a
beautiful
beautiful whiskey i am merely reacting
to your scoffing at me
when i was talking about my you're going
you drink 15
drinks because i because joe 15 drinks i
haven't done that in since i was like
maybe like
you know in my so i haven't done that
now
do not even
i'll i'll go back to let let us revisit
15 drinks
in a week maybe in the summer when we
were doing these bars let us
revisit let us revisit the
gay taste buds was named and sal and i
were sitting in a beach house
pimp it was a vacation at 10 30 a.m
discussing what to name the podcast and
sal said why at 10 30 a.m
why are we not doing this with a beer in
the pool right now
that's 10 30 a.m and you think oh you
think he had two beers
you're talking for yourself about
tuesday no
i'm not i'm saying 15 drinks it says for
a man to be in exodus
but when we're in a pool we went to the
house or voting on a
thing that's the only i'll tell you
another thing that morning that week
like that
if we have a crack the beer in the
morning that's the first time
i've done that i've only that's a
vacation thing except if you
go out on a friday and saturday night
for two solid nights i'm not talking
about
out to a nice dinner in that hotel i
couldn't tell you the last time i went
out for two solid nights of drinking
it has to be i'm not kidding it has to
be i'm not saying two solid nights of
drinking
five plus years i'm not saying two solid
nights with the goal of drinking
i'm saying if you go out for two nights
on the weekend friday and saturday no
you know you know what i think and
leaving you is that i've also started to
dabble in
marijuana yeah yeah and so
you would rather do a legal thing to do
a nice legal drug
drink drink drink drink drink i said to
myself after
at aaron berg's wedding and christine i
said i will never
ever get hung over again that was years
and years and years ago and i don't
believe i have been hungover why what
happened
i drank too much okay but it's an open
bar situation
yeah yeah yeah i don't like weed because
i like to obey the law
yeah that's just me that's not why you
don't like weed okay you don't like weed
because weed
because weed gives you more of what you
don't need
yeah exactly which is neurosis and
anxiety that's like
basically weed is basically your essence
in a plant yeah i know
i smoke you when i smoke weed a lot of
times people smoke weed and they start
to inhibit your treats
it's it's it's horrible it's a heart i
inhabit i don't have it your traits
excuse me
exhibit yeah inhabit
if the traits would inhabit you you
wouldn't inhabit the traits
well you know what i'm saying i think
right i don't know
listen let's get to the argument at hand
and it's proper that we are it's
appropriate that we're talking about
booze because today's topic
is basically bar food great booze soaker
uppers
yeah buffalo wings versus
uh mozzarella sticks yeah or mozzarella
sticks versus buffalo wings
depending on how it was labeled this
week so you guys gotta understand when
we try to pick these battles and by the
way we're going to be discussing a
patreon very soon and live episodes very
soon
and i think in the patreon one of the
things we might do is we might have
people
be able to suggest to us some battles
that they won't want to see
right right so when we try to pick a
battle we really try so we're thinking
apps here right what are some powerhouse
appetizers now granted buffalo wings
could be
a meal in and of themselves but you're
thinking bar food you're thinking
yeah you know that kind of thing and i
think that
you have to find an adversary that's
worthy of each other right
so we came up with buffalo wings and we
said what could go against them when we
thought of
potato skins i think they would dominate
potato skins we thought of french fries
french fries is more of a side
i don't think that's the natural
adversary and then we thought of
mozzarella sticks now
here's what i'm hoping that mozzarella
sticks are as big everywhere as they are
with us and how we were growing up
because if so mozzarella sticks i think
is the proper
contender to buffalo wings well that's
why your team yes and you are team
mozzarella
i'm team buffalo wings because i know a
winner when i see one
and uh if i had to pick between the two
i love mozzarella sticks
but if i had to pick between the two i'm
going buffalo wings all day just based
on sustenance
yeah i'm not going to do that if i had
to pick if you had two in front of me
i have so much to say all right and i'd
like and i'll just
i'll be gonna be pleasant about it
because the last one of the last
episodes i
i turned purple you did and but it was
because you were up to your old ways
you you are he was up to his high drinks
he was up to us some would argue that i
would say
who and he's fools that i was up to your
old ways no
some would argue but would you like to
begin
would you like me to begin i i would cut
i i will say this
out of the gate because i use the term
sustenance already yeah here's what i
prefer the buffalo wing
it's a delicious delicious delicious
thing
anytime there's meat in a meal i take
meat over non-meat anytime
and i like buffalo wings because it's to
me it's more of a complete meal and a
complete meal experience
uh you have the wing you have the varied
dipping sauces i go blue cheese myself
once in a
while i'll go ranch sometimes it's a
breaded wing with hot sauce on it
sometimes it's not i prefer the
non-breaded
um but uh it was sticking to strictly
buffalo sauce
well buffalo wings but you could dip it
into whatever you like that's up for
debate yeah but then but then also too
it always is accompanied by celery and
carrots so i feel like you're getting a
little bit of a vegetable
uh or salad experience on the side
with your buffalo wing look
i stretch you know carrots even i mean
celery i'll give you
all right then celery then i'll just
stick with celery but my point is is
anywhere you get buffalo wings there are
some celery sticks in there
i every time i order i say two things
extra blue cheese
extra celery and i got you down take me
through how you eat the wings
do you finish all the celery do you do
celery in between wing
do you eat a full celery stick in
between your wings what i do often
i go wing wing wing no dip
then you do his wing and then no matter
what several celeries into the blue
cheese as a break
then back to the wings no dip several in
and then i'll start to dip the wings
after a while you don't dip the wings
till the very end
sometimes immediately i dip that because
sometimes i want it to be like a salad
experience on the side i like i like the
the addition of the celery with the blue
cheese
uh what is this cleanser palette is that
what you're doing in the mirror yeah
that's what it's for very refreshing
it's refreshing cooling to cool
okay and i'll buy i i like that i prefer
the drumstick style wings
personally uh and then the and then the
these ones the flat ones
yeah what are those called like i have
no idea
the wings those are the wings i've heard
the the drums it's all the wing
no the drumstick is part of the wing all
right it just looks
like the dresses what do you call those
they're just the uh it's a
it's a full wing just split in half but
yeah one looks like a drumstick and one
look jay calls those flats
big j okarson calls those flats okay and
and people seem to know what he's
talking about i've seen him say in a
restaurant
can i have buffalo wings all flats and
there's all flags yeah and they've got
choices i do all drums that's what i
would do because it's easier to get to
the meat but when i have a flat
i'll bite each side of it to get some
chicks
skin and chicken off either side and
then there's that stuff in the middle
and then i split it from the top
oh you're talking about things that one
of the reasons i
don't like buffalo wings you don't like
them no no
no like one of the cases i would make
against them because i will tell you
i have to be in the mood for buffaloing
um
when they're good they're great when
they're bad they're not that good
but i you won't drop a buff a plate of
buffalo wings in front of me and 100 of
the time i'm like
buffalo wings i'll have some i kind of
have to be like i'd like a buffalo wing
or i'd not like one
if you dropped a plate of mozzarella
sticks in front of me at any point
at any point i'll probably go in for one
i have rolled the dice far more times on
buffalo wings than i have on mozzarella
sticks
any time i order mozzarella sticks my
first question is how are the mozzarella
sticks
because you're gambling with a lot first
of all are you getting a battered
mozzarella stick or they're breaded
that makes a huge difference second of
all what is the quality of the
mozzarella what's the difference being
battered and breaded well
battered is almost like a funnel cake
type of uh breading on it and then
and then the breaded is the better
that's the one that's like a sort of
mealy
bread crummy you know what i mean it's
not the same thing no
no see you can see that i mean
they all look the same no no go up pimp
that on the left is a battered
oh that oh that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about on the right you
you will encounter that and on the right
is a breadcrumb
yeah that that could go take a walk so
so you're dealing with that you're
dealing with the quality of the
mozzarella
you're dealing with is it is it a
mozzarella that that adheres
uh adheres to the breading itself or am
i gonna bite into it and get a lot of
liquidy
hot oily drip which is disgusting then
you can't have a mozzarella stick
without marinara and if you get bad
marinara with it it doesn't matter how
good those
you're in you're in the that's it i will
tell you forget it i i agree with you
that the the sauce can sink the dish
but i don't necessarily think you even
need sauce because if you had them
without sauce i'd polish the whole plate
as well
i think that you'll eat them without
marinara of course most people what i
believe
i think that's i put down on beautiful
pyramid worth of golden mozzarella
sticks and i'm like i don't have any
sauce
you're gonna be like hot pass on my end
i mean i might eat one
but it's like i would be like i'd be
like
it's like it's like i would eat the
whole pyramid at that point to me it's
like putting out pretzels
i'm like no it's fine no no no no no no
so
mozzarella you just you are going to
grill cheese recently mozzarella cheese
is
arguably my favorite cheese i'm one of
the most popular cheeses there is
mozzarella cheese is the main component
of a mozzarella stick right mozzarella
to me without sauces
that's to you i don't know that's to
everybody right that's my opinion about
material sticks
usually you're not getting a gourmet
mozzarella stick so the baseline
for a judgment of a montreal stick is
the your typical diner stick
and those diner mozzarella sticks come
in a bag frozen and those things
are pretty common across all the land so
when i'm judging the mozzarella stick
i'm even judging it
at its lowest point a frozen bag that
comes with 70 of them in there
and they dump them into a fryer and you
eat them and there's nothing special
about the mozzarella cheese it's not
this elevated mozzarella
it's your standard so for me to think
that most of all sticks are still
amazing and can go
up against buffalo wings at the baseline
mozzarella stick means anything above
that
is even gets even better i'm i'm able to
judge this and argue for mozzarella
sticks at its lowest form i could argue
this i know
stick a frozen food aisle mozzarella
stick i could
that is wrong you cannot buy good
mozzarella sticks in the grocery store
no you cannot
i don't care what you say it doesn't
matter it's harder to mess up a
mozzarella stick
than it is to mess up a buffalo buffalo
wing is the cheapest part of the chicken
the wing easy peasy
in a hot sauce which is usually butter
mixed with hot sauce
but sometimes i'll eat a buffalo wing
and there's so many variables
with the wing that could go wrong give
me these variables sometimes there's
like extra
rubbery tendons in there there's extra
fat on it
sometimes you bite into it and it's just
not great
meat there's not great breading uh
sometimes
the buffalo sauce is suspect some people
do it right some people don't
sometimes it's a big leaky oily mess
and the sauce is just everywhere and
it's just like
it's just like they just douse it in
there and they let it sopping wet this
is a great way to make a buffalo and
it's a terrible way i think it's
i think you're rolling the dice more
often ordering blind off a menu
i'll take the buffalo wing i'll take the
montreal stick i think you're gonna have
more consistency with the mozzarella
stick you're
you're taking more risk with the buffalo
wing depending on who you are where you
are
and all i have to do with i have two
gauntlet
throwing arguments against your
mozzarella stick
okay number one you go ahead because i
have more to say as well oh you do okay
good
number one i'll start with this one and
then i'll let you talk
and then i'll talk some more number one
mozzarella stick i give it what out of
the fryer
six minutes before it's uneditable about
six minutes
before a gentleman freezes
it into a rock hard polio string cheese
this is where i'm gonna get a little bit
heated with red on it that's where i'm
gonna get a little heated with you guys
by the way what's better than a poly or
string cheese
not much right what's the mozzarella
they're five string cheese bread
they're fine they're fine but i'll tell
you what i'm never getting is when when
you show me a
thing of mozzarella sticks and then a
thing next to it of mozzarella with
prosciutto wrapped around it every time
i'm buying it with the prosciutto
wrapper
you're bringing in a high-end food now
and you're i'm not
i'm telling you that mozzarella is not
great on it you're bringing in
prosciutto
i'm just saying mozzarella is better
when it has something with it that's not
true mozzarella
i can make it arguably for it being one
of the things that is the best on its
own
bar none it's it never never exists you
almost don't need anything but
mozzarella it never says
the most popular cheese in the world
what do you think it is okay
great well thank god for
spinneyfields.com that's got to be
accurate
here's my point okay let's just ask
google what's the most popular cheese in
the united states
mozzarella okay 33 pounds of cheese
reveal i want you
i want you to name me mozzarella
mozzarella surpassed
cheddar as america's most popular cheese
for the second year in a row okay great
in 2011. uh but you're saying but here
but you're saying it doesn't stand on it
let's talk shipping
shipping shipping shipping i love
talking shipping
i mean i want to talk ship station is
what you want to talk about not just any
old shipping
shipping with ship station and not just
shipping but how your shipping could be
more productive yeah if you're somebody
that sells stuff online
well you're definitely in the right
business especially now yeah more people
are
online shopping than ever sure uh and
that means that you got
your orders coming in you got your
orders going out and you need to ship
out fast that's why online sellers like
you need shipstation yeah
so this is basically going to aggregate
all the different delivery methods and
tell you what's the quickest easiest
most affordable way
to ship stuff out you can import stuff
from any sales channel
you can ship with any carrier you access
all the discounted shipping rates and
you automate it uh
just about any shipping desk you have
basically having like
uh a ship center apply it to your own
business it's giving you let it yeah
it's it's making this
sort of thing cost you a much greater
less
amount of time yeah a much greater less
amount of time yeah
a much it's it's making all i'm gonna
ship i'm gonna ship you a bunch of
dictionaries
yeah it's making shipping easier so you
can spend your time growing your
business is what i'm trying to get at
100 and it has a fully mobile app okay
and no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website ship station
funnels
all your orders into one simple
interface and then you manage the orders
from there even from your cell phone
ship more and less time just use our
offer code which is taste buds to get
60 free days a 60 free day trial that's
two months free
no hassle stress free shipping just go
to shipstation.com
click on that microphone at the top of
the page and type in
tastebuds shipstation.com enter offer
code taste buds
i was going to say it the second time
but you know you jumped in
make ship happen i gave you that
like to talk to you a moment about
lucy.cojo
lucy.com because you used to smoke like
a chimney like a chimp
yeah i still do you still do and i want
to wean you off and at lucy.com
lucy lucy is a nicotine alternative that
i i think you're really benefiting i
have been using
lucy gum yeah and it has helped me cut
down significantly
on my cigarette intake uh significantly
i mean that and it really hits the spot
for me
and at the times when you can't smoke
and you don't feel like going outside
because it's 22 degrees it's true it's
convenient it's discreet
products can be enjoyed anywhere like
you said on flights at work on the go at
the gym
uh the flavors just like wintergreen
cinnamon pomegranate they have
everything in them
there's four milligrams of nicotine in
the cherry ice flavor because they also
have that as a lozenge
okay yeah and you know what i like about
it too is the gum
tasted like gum to me it didn't taste
like nicotine gum
yeah just tasted like gum regular gum
yeah but you still felt the effects of
it so that's that's kind of a hard thing
to find with
with cigarette uh replacement gum
and you know it's 20 21 guys get rid of
the cigarettes unplug your vape
throughout your dip
and get some lucy nicotine gum or
lozenges it's the real deal
uh they do it by subscription so a
subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door each month
it's simple you don't have to leave your
house they have delivery down for the
taste buds listeners
you're gonna go to lucy.co that's co.com
lucy.co
use the promo code tastebuds and get 20
off all the products on your first order
um
including gum and lozenges yeah that's
lucy.co
and use promo code taste buds at
checkout also
i have to give this disclaimer uh this
is a warning this product
contains nicotine derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical that
said
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code
taste taste buds hey sal
if my name was fresh and i came to your
door what would you say to me hello
fresh
what a coincidence our new sponsor is
hello fresh i love actually i really
like hello fresh i love trying to get
into cooking now
which i never could do before with
hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door hellofresh
lets you skip those trips to the grocery
store
and makes home cooking easy fun and
affordable
and it's that's why it's america it's
america's number one meal kit did you
know that
because there's other competitors but
this is the number one yeah and you know
what's funny
there used to uh it used to be a joke in
comedy
uh you know i don't know if one comic
did it or many comics did it but people
would make comments about
you know oh cooking looks so easy on tv
when everything's already partialed
out for you or whatever that's what
hellofresh does for you
it gives you everything just like it's a
neat little cooking show
it presents it here you go and you one
two three follow the directions and
that's it
get better value with hellofresh that
sounds like a great bit
wasn't my bit no just sounds like
somebody's bit sounds great
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning is what he's saying
okay and it offers 10 to 20 minute meals
which is like
i mean you can't give that's quicker
than delivery yeah these are low prep
reps recipes
it's quick breakfast quick lunches quick
that way quick everything perfect for
your busy schedule
get better value hellofresh is 28
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store
and 72 cheaper than a restaurant meal
without sacrificing quality okay so
there it is i've been ordering them i've
been cooking again
uh i've started getting more confident
in my cooking it really lays it out for
you it kind of makes it fun i find
cooking cathartic i think
yeah and so i'm really liking it so go
to hellofresh.com slash
taste buds 12 why the 12 you ask that's
easy
you use taste buds 12 for the code and
you get 12
free meals plus shipping it's amazing
free meals sometimes i eat once a day
that means they giving me enough meals
to provide me for a third of a month
yeah and if you only ate half a meal a
day
it'd be twice how about this if i eat a
third of a meal a day
i'd have over a free month's worth of
food from hellofresh
uh hellofresh is not recommending you do
that
that's just us having some math fun here
because we like to learn
as we talk uh repeat the offer folks
hellofresh.com buds 12
you're going to get 12 free meals
including shipping it's highly
encouraged
to voice the following america
you're reading the you what is it
listen to me go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds12
and then also use the code tastebuds12
for the 12 free meals including shipping
okay hello fresh
america's number one meal kit joe yes
sir
i travel a lot really yes you know one
of my most prized possessions is when
i'm traveling
cannot leave the house without it
headphones correct passport and
headphones yeah
passport well it depends on where you're
going well i just like sometimes it's
just
iowa yeah but i still that passports can
represent identification as well
you'd have to go into national passport
sure you know there if you want to roll
in like an fbi agent
flip it up yeah but the other thing i
love is is my headphones and my earbuds
and my wireless earbuds let me tell you
who i've been using lately raycon babe
i've been using raycon myself
and that head buds earbuds
headphones market whatever you want to
call it
it's a tough one right now it's intense
it's very competitive and there's a lot
of extremely high prices out there and i
love
that raycon has stepped into the fight
to shake things up
and create a very quality amazingly
simple to use bluetooth earbud uh
or set of earbuds that is so
fairly priced it's insane yeah i know
you
you don't want to turn me onto them
actually no dangling wires or stems to
get in your way
uh raycons come in a range of of stylish
colors
but always with a comfortable in-ear fit
for a more discreet look
uh tons of battery life yeah i think six
hours of play time you can unplug for a
while and enjoy yourself
uh and i love these things particularly
because they sync right up with your
phone there is none of that nonsense of
the phone needs to recognize it or
doesn't recognize it and it's not
clicking in and it's not which is
infuriating by the way it's the worst
it's the work it'll it'll make you
return headphones
these boom they're right there raycon's
offering 15
off all of their products for our
listeners and here's what you got to do
you go to buy recon dot com
b u y r a y c o n dot com
slash taste buds and that's it you'll
get 15
off your entire raycon order so feel
free to grab a pair of earbuds
and despair what have you yeah that's 15
off
at byraycon.com taste buds that's by
raycon dot com slash taste buds
grab a pear and a spare [ __ ] i'm gonna
say something it doesn't stand on its
own and here's why it doesn't stand on
its own
it doesn't mean it's the most popular
cheese because people love it on its own
it means it's the most popular cheese
because its sales are high its sales are
high because it is used in several
different dishes
nobody has ever every parmesan dish sure
pizza right and why do you think they
use that cheese because it meshes well
with other
flavors it's not the best cheese it's
not it meshes well with other food
you go into a reason pizza is so good
you know one of the one of the biggest
salad you get mozzarella sticks yeah
yeah yeah you get a salad you get a
strawberry
that's because of the sauce sticks yeah
that's because the sauce
uh you get a salad you get a what's that
salad called in this in the steakhouse
with the tomato and the basil leaves
you've never been crazy
yeah a caprese salad it's it's
mozzarella with base
with basil with tomato with balsamic you
when you get a cheese
platter it doesn't have mozzarella are
you eating just
a slice of mozzarella i'm ordering the
mozzarella stick which comes with sauce
and it's spreading in front of me i'm
saying
don't don't don't don't call up my
cousin don't go pumping up mozzarella to
me i got two you guys
first of all i would argue exactly
opposite what you said that
i'll give it six minutes before a
mozzarella stick is no good anymore out
of the fryer
i think mozzarella sticks are one of the
things that keep the absolute best
they maybe maybe they're not hot anymore
but they're still crispy and a couple of
hours later if i had a tray out
i'd go in for a month two hours in a
tray like nobody's business
it's a different texture it's a
different experience like it's you're
crunchy but it's colder
it's not a little bit it's not crunchy
it's hard those are two different things
you can't say
crunchy it's hard it's battered and
fried and it's crunchy
cold chicken cold chicken everybody
loves cold chicken cold chickens
people take it on picnics literally i
literally think my people
take it off every picnic i've ever seen
in a movie
the lady pulls cold chicken out of a
basket every picnic i've ever seen in a
movie
i would argue that buffalo wings i would
apply what you said to buffalo wings
did you not keep if i'm done with a
buffalo wing it's like a half hour it's
sitting in that plate and it's getting
all coagulated
and it's getting all like let's talk a
sauceless buffalo wing let's talk
one of the ones where they make the
breading spicy because what those are
also referred to as buffalo wings
that that cold is delicious i'm talking
about traditional buffalo but okay
whatever whatever okay okay fine
now let me let me throw this other
gauntlet argument at you excuse me
i had a little bit of a burp i'm sorry
guess what i've never seen pimp in a bar
ever in my life hey guys make sure you
come in monday for mozzarella stick
night
that's never happened you could take you
could take such a walk
bro first of all first of all mozzarella
sticks are more well-liked than buffalo
wings because not everybody
likes spice so right off the bat
everyone they're not like
or they would have mozzarella stick
night that's not true
that's not true because what you're
doing is because because buffalo wings
can also be eaten as their main meal
you order a dozen buffalo wings that
that that could
serve as more than an app but usually
people aren't which makes it
okay if you want to keep giving me
accolades thank you what are you talking
about dude if you go to a barge usually
half price
apps i know they have wing night that
doesn't make it any better than this
wing
by the way what's the two most sold
things at a diner for people
that want to eat after drinking
something it's a mozzarella stick
or it's like a disco frog you'll see
you'll see buffalo wings
in diners across this country yes you're
gonna find regionally
nah people don't eat buffalo wings when
they're like i'm drunk i need to fill my
stomach with something
people don't eat buffalo wings when
they're drunk
the only time you eat them no you need
pictures of
two dollar pitchers and buffalo wings
that's not when you're drunk that's when
you're getting drunk
when you're drunk and you're like we
gotta go get something to eat and you go
to a diner
it's disco fries or mozzarella sticks
i'll take
a dozen red hot buffalo wings at 2 a.m
nobody does that i'll tell you nothing i
got news for you
mozzarella sticks aren't in that k in
that camp either that's not true
oh i'm hoping i'm hoping that people
feel nationwide about mozzarella sticks
the way that we do here in new york
if so i think i have a really good
chance at winning this
is the ultimate app the
ultimate app how could you say that i i
said it with my mouth based on what
you're saying you're saying mozzarella
cheese with breadcrumbs around it
is the ultimate app even that's simple
cold without sauce
yeah that's insane buffalo wings can be
disgusting
so can mozzarella sticks so popular
please finish your thing oh does anybody
talk about by the way
does anybody ever talk about where was
the where was the mozzarella stick
invented
no heard that story about buffalo wings
quite a bit buffalo's in the title man
it's in the title but i've heard that
story quite a bit everybody wants to
visit the bar in buffalo new york where
where the first thought was when you say
what it is then you're just saying a
wing
but mozzarella doesn't mozzarella stick
doesn't need to be
nobody has ever said who would have the
mozzarella stick
that doesn't matter bro it does no it
doesn't work
what matters is you drop mozzarella a
plate of mozzarella sticks in front of
someone a plate of buffalo wings in
front of someone
what are they reaching for most often i
promise you i promise you there have
been more
television episodes on the food network
like that mark summer show or whatever
where they have devoted the entire
episode to the invention of the buffalo
wing and why it started and where it
came
that's because it comes from buffalo
they claim it
other people make it is it is good
there's variations in sausages every
food
everything there's chicken i'm talking
about everything but every
it is an app no buffalo wings are an app
they're listed as an app but
it goes back to what i said before it's
easier to mess up a buffalo wing than
i'm going to disagree with this
is breaded fried cheese that's why
you're not having food now
because it's a simple debate hold on
every michelin star chef in the world is
like oh a mozzarella stick
no i'm telling you well guess what guess
what else michelin star chefs do
they'll do they'll do a schmidt they'll
do a shmance wing they won't do a
schmance mozzarella stick because it's
breaded
cheese and that's and i'll tell you
another thing guess what i can make from
scratch at home
buffalo wings guess what i can't make
from scratch at home
mozzarella sticks are you scared
there's the one comment that comes per
episode that makes zero
[ __ ] sense ever i can go downstairs
right now you can blindfold me i will
feel my way down the steps with my own
hands
i will get me i will chop up some
mozzarella i will i will i will bread it
and i will put in the fryer and i'll
make my chocolate sticks without you
you have a fryer downstairs you just
happen to have a fryer i will lightly
fry a pan with some oil
and i will put the cheese in there and
maybe i am telling you something
when you said it you can't make fries
you can cut it out because you don't
have a deep fryer i'm speaking to what
you said
which was so
do you think it's harder for you to bake
a bunch of wings
yes and then mix them in a hot sauce yes
and then eat them yes
with blue cheese you pour it out of a
jar yes then to just take a piece of
cheese
and lay it in some oil stop yes come on
we'll go downstairs right now he'll take
the camera off the tripod
and we will start two different stations
and have a game of chopped
and i will make i will make mozzarella
sticks quicker easier and better
than you can make chicken from scratch
buffalo wings from scratch downstairs
and i'm
i'm not even getting to the other part i
don't like you know what happens to me i
would take that i would take that back
well
then you should because i'll take it as
well i would take that you want to test
me you can test
you know what happens when i'm eating
chicken wings sometimes the same thing
it has the same thing as a sushi
phenomenon to me sometimes i love sushi
but every once in a while
i'll be like knee deep in some sushi
like my second roll
with another roll coming and i'm like
what am i doing i'm chewing on just raw
fish and sometimes that gets into my
head and i go oh i don't want sushi
right now
but i love sushi but every once in a
while you have a one piece it's a little
off or just
you just start to realize you're a
little full with sushi and you're like
i'm really getting full on food that's
some
sometimes i don't love pulling flesh off
a bone
do you notice what i'm saying okay
sometimes i don't mind it but sometimes
all of a sudden i realize what i'm doing
and i just feel like a cave person and
i'm like and when you put
when you put the the flats in your mouth
and you hold them and then you go
and you pull out two bones yeah jerry
styles
the meat the flesh sometimes i go oh and
i shudder and i go
i'm i'm like a savage right now i mean
i'm just i'm just if
you wanna when you're trying to get in
there and you're like there's a little
piece of and you just
you're working around if we wanna own
sometimes i get turned off and i go
what am i doing and i have to stop
eating the wings if we wanna argue
which foods is sal too weak to eat
i mean that's fine that's a different
episode giving you the reason like think
there's thing that strikes
buffalo wings but that's not for me
buffalo wings have strikes against them
i don't think that's a very fair strike
because here's why
i can always hear myself but here's what
but hold on here's why
i don't think that's a fair strike
because that's like a vegetarian saying
oh well well that's meat so i think it's
worse
it's no that's something we're arguing
here what we're arguing here
is the quality of one dish versus the
other and what can't play into that
is i have a weird thing in my head where
i get creeped out
i'm telling you why i choose mozzarella
sticks first
we're also speaking to a greater
audience here which is what is the
crowning app
and i think that some people won't like
the spice i think people will all have
their own issues with either for
whatever reason they choose either is
fine
one of the reasons i don't love wings
all the time and i have to be in the
mood
is you are just ripping some some
some flesh off a bone and i don't always
love it
i'm i don't always like going and then
just looking at bone
and there's a plate of bones that's
getting higher and higher in front of me
and this is like blue cheese and orange
swirls and that's a messier dish i'll
give you that
i know but i sometimes i also i'll tell
you another problem with buffalo wings
i mean uh with mozzarella sticks excuse
me one dip in the sauce is not enough
you
always need that second dip so it's a
very hard food to share
buffalo wings you can do one dip in the
butt in the in the blue cheese if you
want or not dip it all and enjoy it
mozzarella sticks you dip once you bite
it needs that second dip
you can't double dip because you're
sharing with somebody so that's why it's
hard to share
okay so what are you doing when you're
sharing wings with blue cheese
same as i just said blue cheese wings
only require one dip they don't require
a double maybe where you
mozzarella sticks require a double dip
odd blanket statement
it's not an odd blanket no it's not so
all wings take only one dip and all
mozzarella sticks take two you have a
much better chance
you have a much better chance with a
single dip of a buffalo wing than you do
with a single dip of mozzarella stick
and i will tell you this too
here's why because you can if you don't
get enough blue cheese on that one dip
which i find that you do
you can enjoy the other bite on its own
without the
without a second
that's not true you don't need marinara
sauce to do go to uh
mozzarella stick it's in my hand right
now i'm dipping i'm biting
i'm flipping oh yeah that's what i
wanted
the part that your dirty friggin thumbs
touched i want it going into the sauce i
mean
yeah right that's great you can't dip a
buffalo wing twice
we're not even getting but you dip it
and you go we we're not even
getting into the others
a buffalo wing is a wing with buffalo
sauce
there are no other flavors
do me a favor i want you to go to the
restaurant that invented
the buffalo wing okay and i want you to
i want these are buffalo wings this is
who invented them anchor bar
in buffalo new york i just want you to
look at the buffalo just tell me if they
have any other flavors besides the
standard buffalo if they do
if they don't then i'm wrong i just
solicitors i think
even the ones banker bar menu i think
our listeners are going to revolt
against you i'm
i'm just asking a question of what
defines one flavor we're talking about
it's
buffalo i'm asking i just said if i'm
wrong
okay buffalo and what
no this is the to-go stuff go up pimp go
up to the top to home
there should be a menu on home somewhere
uh let's see what they have let's see
what they have let's just see what they
have
i'm i'm asking can i not ask a question
is that okay
am i allowed to ask a question i know
the answer all right
i don't know the answer you have to
argue for buffalo wing that's the recipe
look at this you're right i just wanted
to know
what did you want to see joe if they had
what what give me another flavor that
might have been there
what about spicy barbecue that's not a
buffalo wing
okay joe you know that joe what about
now i think you're going in what about
yeah lemon garlic that's not a buffalo
wing joe oh
oh my god yeah see they got different
flavors
joe they got different flavors and it's
the place in buffalo oh no this isn't
the place okay i was just curious
i was just asking a question you just
named lemon garlic and
barbecue so are you arguing buffalo
buffalo wild wings serves all types of
flavors
and they're called buffalo wild wings
you're a smart kid i'm asking
stop stop trying to stop trying to bring
in barbecue wings and lemongrass
a question i don't do did i tell you
what about
a different flavor of fried cheese no
there isn't one i'm sure there is
there isn't one no there's no fry any
cheese oh oh you could fry anything i
could fry
bleep that i could fly cucumbers up if i
wanted to you can find anything you want
but i'm talking about mozzarella so i'm
not gonna go into other cheeses you're
talking about mozzarella sticks
mozzarella is in the name
buffalo does not mean hot buffalo means
buffalo new york
it means buffalo sauce that's what it
means you know that's what it means
and why is it called buffalo sauce
because it was invented right now on
your behalf as a friend for another
friend
that is making a real the optics on this
for you are bad
the optics are bad we've argued enough
right you you you
there is one point the fans are bringing
up you haven't mentioned which is the
tie
of buffalo wings to sports and how
american that is
yeah that says it all that's bar food
sports is sports bar
bars bar food i think mozzarella sticks
are as bar food as
wings you think that i can't not number
one
wings are the bigger bars i can't
believe the bigger
no we're not arguing what's the most
popular we're arguing what we think
people taste bad what do you think
people taste
i know but you have brought up several
times that you think mozzarella sticks
are the ultimate app they're not
buffalo wings are the ultimate app i
don't think they are
all right we've argued enough can we go
to the polls let's go to the polls i
mean
we've got 19 000 votes here okay that
might be our biggest ever
okay okay yeah let's let's let's
let's read no no i like to do that do we
want to do that before
fan favorite tweet or after well well i
like to get a breath of what people are
saying
okay i'm sorry i forgot how we do it i
forget
boy i hope someone doesn't i want to
tell you something i really
tried to maintain my composure this
episode you did because i no but i could
have blew my top again
why would you blow your tongue because
you have you know how to push my buttons
i'm having some fun with you i
understand but yeah but i really i'm
happy i saw myself last time almost have
a full stroke live on the air
i i said just when he does this to you
just take a beat
count to ten take some deep breaths i
was doing practicing breathing exercises
and because i didn't want it's always
just me shouting at you
so but i want to tell you though inside
i want to yell
i want to yell a lot because i don't
like i really don't like the way you
approach these arguments have a drink
calm down
[Music]
okay because
sometimes you don't you don't argue you
don't are you fair i
asked a question i still don't
understand what you're so upset about
all i said was go to the place that
invented buffalo wigs and tell me if
they serve other flavors
and they didn't and i said sal you're
right and for some reason
that's still not they would have served
barbecue wings or lemon garlic wings
then i don't think there would be room
to argue
and that's what i'm telling you but it
does it's moot
i was wrong and i said i'm wrong and
you're right you're wrong just because
that one restaurant didn't happen
then your argument would be right to me
you would be changing your argument on
nonsense to me it would be like hold on
let me just say this
let me just say this to me it would be
like saying
for instance a grilled cheese couldn't
be grilled gouda because traditionally
that's not what a grilled cheese is
and then we found the restaurant that
invented grilled cheese and they said
we have a grilled cheese with gouda we
have a grilled cheese with swiss
and then i would make the oregano okay
it could be gouda grilled
that's the only thing i'm saying cheese
unless we
unless we designate it's traditional
grilled cheese
we in that argument i gave you any
cheese i was fair
i know wings
i did buffalo sauce
i didn't know what i thought it was
called buffalo wings because buffalo
they were invented in buffalo they were
but that particular sauce guess what
buffalo wild wings called
sauce we're talking guess what buffalo
wild wings calls your buffalo sauce your
precious buffalo sauce the
the biggest hot wing chain in the
country guess what they call your
buffalo sauce sal
guess it's not mine okay take it take a
wild guess what
traditional they don't call it buffalo
sauce they call it traditional
that's why i asked the question buffalo
wild question
dictate your august i asked a question
and i immediately said i was wrong
you you're bowing down to the corporate
bigwigs mozzarella sticks not owned by
anybody palace
only the people how about this you bow
down
and kiss my ass
bleep it bleep it he's always got to go
to the f he's always got to go
you said that three four times until i
know i didn't say it on purpose though
it slipped out
slipped out all right go ahead go ahead
go ahead go mr all sticks on the single
white mothers of the appetizer
what as soon as you move out on your own
you love them for how hard they tried
buff what am i understanding hold
are the single white mothers of the
appetizer yeah you move out on your own
you realize as soon as you move out on
your own you
love them yeah for how hard they try in
other words you sucked at being a mom
chicken wings are the first college
girlfriend hot and wild and you're drunk
most of the time
that does nothing for me chris chris i
love that tweet
here we go i love you brian breeslaw
get ready for one guy to talk about the
thousand different variations of wing
flames
and heat and the other to turn red in
the face thing that's against the rules
so oh we didn't go and i love you
viscaluso however you say this
so many variations sauces rubs dipping
sauces of a buffalo wing
also have you ever had a freshly dipped
battered mozzarella fried mozzarella
doubtful all frozen thank you
i'll put frozen mozzarella sticks up
against look at this
actually i should have even brought up i
should have even brought up hot ones
they get a
they got the most popular show on
youtube is dedicated to the hot ones
that's just
to see people's levels of pain and by
the way and by the way
and by the way his flavors they're not
all just traditional shout out
uh uh shout out shout out he's not doing
all traditional
uh just shout out sean evans he's got
some fruit flavors and things in there i
love what they're doing over there
but do you well tell him his sausages
don't count but but it doesn't matter
that that show is
they want to see your threshold for
scoville units bro you can't oh that has
no place in our argument i'll argue it
all day
i eat wings more commonly so when i have
a good materialistic i'm leaning towards
that
okay you ever hear someone just go out
for mozzarella sticks like wings
nah it's a very tough choice but almost
always you can get good mozzarella
sticks
wings on the other hand really depend on
the bar restaurant someone without a
doubt better than others
gonna be interesting to see team
mozzarella thank you
[Music]
this is by far the hardest one you guys
have done wow
the cheesy goodness of a mutt stick but
the variations of buffalo wings you
don't have national
uh overruled variations of buffalo wings
no it's not overruled just for variety
purposes buffalo wings would be better
take that out of the argument this is
where i'm gonna lose not over
this is why i'm saying to you it was a
valid question to ask
wait wait go back up that's what i'm
saying you too you don't have to
you don't have national chains of
mozzarella sticks but wingstop and
buffalo wild wings are always hot spots
of a town or city
what i said to you i'm not sure how
these are comparable buffalo wings can
be a meal
mozzarella sticks are really a snack see
so
so people are going to pick it up from
that hand that's tough you pick what you
pick
but i told you from the beginning a lot
of people don't see buffalo wings as
just an app
i'm not interested in what a lot of
people are going to see
buffalo wings are an app it's not my
fault if people don't do their research
i love you both but i can never say no
to some good old mozzarella sticks
cheese in general will always win deep
fried cheese will always win
even if i disagree with sal's choice i
already know he has a better argument
joe's argument is always it's always
that the only version he's ever had of
sal's pick
has come from a dumpster
[Laughter]
there you go big surprise big surprise
the
fans think sal so smart oh
oh so i think you know what it was
america's sweetheart
oh god i just love him yes i am i saw
him
i'm not gonna apologize
shake a guy's hand with a hand buzzer on
true tv
oh he's a genius
[Laughter]
[Music]
no that never happened but nothing
nothing let me write myself a note
that's what the critics do they boil our
show down to a hand buzzer
and it ain't that buddy boy you don't
get 10 years on a hand buzzer
all right my look my vote for the win is
the first guy is my favorite the single
white mother
like i think that's that's hands down
the funniest one we've read
and i'm not picking it because it's size
okay chris lay at
c-t-o-p-h-e-r-11986 follow him he gets
the win today
uh give him a retweet and uh 20
233 votes oh dude and this is only in
the first half hour
twenty thousand votes people are for
this one all right people are amped all
right
ready yeah here we go let's have a
humble pie segment let's get a drum roll
in here
54 goes to buffalo wings
i mean that was very very very close
much closer than i thought it was you're
proud
you're talking you're talking over 20
000 votes
less than a 5 margin and honestly i
think buffalo wings
was the favorite going in so to have
that small of a margin
it's a tough loss but i feel really good
it wasn't a blowout
you know what i'm saying right i feel
really good that mozzarella
i will i will say it is much closer than
i thought it was gonna be
but i am still happy to take a win i bet
you if you did this regional and this
was a new york poll
what's wrong sticks oh listen we can
live in fantasylands all we want but
that's not what the show is and that's
not what the game is what's the most
but despite all that i still love you
buddy i love you too
all right that's our show it is our show
all right thanks for tuning in folks uh
check us out on youtube if you're
probably already doing that thank you to
everybody subscribing check us out on
tick tock follow us on there
leave on youtube subscribe leave a
thumbs up hit that like button
uh uh leave a review please please
subscribe we're noticing
the majority of people watching are not
subscribed
it's crazy they watch we get the numbers
are going crazy we want to say thank you
we actually finally charted
on the top comedy podcast finally this
week that's all because of you guys
thank you for
catching on now uh our numbers are
jumping they're doubling and tripling
now
we just got to get the word out that's
what it's all about so please subscribe
to the uh
no pressure network on youtube also we
have a no pressure tick tock now
and we're going to have a new clips page
coming out on youtube
with the best of the best clips so you
can just kind of like watch little
segments if you want
uh what else what else what else that's
it we'll see you next time
yeah on taste buds okay yeah yeah taste
buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds taste buds better put on your
boots make sure they're laced up
what does that have to do with it
[Music]
you